did you ever wonder about that closed
door in Cathedral Ward you know the one
it's below the church giant with the
ball and chain and past the room where
you rolled through all the pots it's the
sort of door you forget about even if
you finish the game but think about it
now you never open that door did you
well you're not alone
no one's opened this door yet and
perhaps no one ever will but we do know
where it leads the cliff we're on
overlooks the Great Bridge where we
fought the cleric beast and it's no
great leap of logic to assume this store
is the same door as the one at the end
of the bridge but what is interesting to
note is that from software actually put
the effort in to make these two doors
align perfectly in the world let's prove
it go over to the door and throw down a
couple of shining coins actually through
40 this is the only time in the game
these are useful go crazy with it then
run all the way to the great bridge
without reloading your game and the door
at the end we'll have your shining coins
on it still which proves that these
parts of the world are connected in both
the law and physically chances are you
could probably unlock this shortcut once
upon a time but in the game's current
state it doesn't make much sense for it
to exist so they must have only removed
half of it while we're in central
yharnam let's go over the things I
missed last episode because you guys
taught me a lot so during this fight
with Gascoigne you would have found the
red jeweled brooch upon his wife's
corpse you take this brooch to their
daughter and she'll cry upon realizing
that both her parents are dead
alternatively if you smash the brooch to
get the gem you can talk to the girl and
send her to the chapel just past
Gascoigne's boss fight but most of you
probably already know that the
interesting thing is what can happen
next
so whichever one you chose reload your
game and you'll realize that she's left
her house she's now left for the chapel
but you never actually see her show up
there right so where did she end up well
this little girl crept along through the
sewers only to be consumed by the giant
pig at the end of this long dark tunnel
the proof of this is that the pig now
drops the red messenger ribbon with the
red color drawn from the organs of some
unfortunate victim a strange choice but
perhaps for the messengers wearing this
accessory constitutes some form of
mourning
öand dude did you know that if you
summon Gascoigne and bring him to his
daughters window in central yharnam
nothing happens there was someone in the
last videos comments who said I had to
try that out
dammit I'm so hopeful something would
happen but that's something you might
not know you can summon Gascoigne for
help against the cleric beast if you use
the summoning bell right outside the
central yharnam Lantern but are we were
supposed to be talking about Cathedral
Ward so let's go up the path that the
chief hunter himself would have used
after you defeat the cleric beast and by
his emblem from the messengers you can
unlock the main gate by inspecting it
when you walk through though cast your
eyes down to the pavement you can
actually see an eye engraved in the
stone and I think this is a bit of a
clue because I think it means that if
you have enough insight you'll actually
be able to see the messengers that are
gathered around the lever it's almost
like the messengers here recognize the
item you bought from the messengers in
the dream and pull the lever for you
since this is the only lever I'm aware
of that has messengers crowd around it
like this Cathedral Ward in general is
one of those places that reveals a ton
of new details if you have enough
insight with 15 insight Church doctors
are revealed to have eyeballs crowded
around their lanterns and their sights
become imbued with more power and the
doctors with the crucifix have it
covered in flame as well if you have 40
insight you'll be able to see the giant
Cthulhu monster that's been hanging off
the church this entire time that's the
thing that grabs you when you try to
pick up the hunter set in the courtyard
anyway once you've opened the main gate
you can trigger Eileen the crows second
appearance by opening the gate that's
just next to the wooden plank shield
she's hard to spot but she's standing
just below the giant Cthulhu monster
outside the front entrance to oedon
chapel she tells us of henrique who is a
hunter who's currently residing in the
tomb of odin and that's where you killed
Gascoigne Gascoigne was an old friend
Henriques and now henrique has gone mad
with grief presumably after realizing
that Gascoigne passed away it's Eileen's
job to put him down because as we saw
with Gascoigne hunters who go mad are a
threat to everybody and hunters turn
into the most horrific
she gives you the gesture here and tells
us to keep it a secret
so naturally we reload our game and
decide to blunder into the tomb of Odin
here Eileen is patiently waiting to
assassinate Henry that's two against one
here but the real difficulty comes from
not actually hitting Eileen while you're
trying to kill Henrique if you're not
careful you can actually make Eileen
hostile to you which is not a good thing
because she does talk to you afterwards
killing Henrique unlocks his set for
purchase in the dream and Eileen will
give you the approval gesture he'll need
the hunting pointed to me eileen is just
one of the many npcs in cathedral ward
though there are so many in this area
it's probably one of the most densely
populated areas to find all these NPCs
you just need to move most of them to
Odin chapel
so after you've talked to the dweller
he'll beg you to ask others to seek the
chapel as a safe haven the incense
Ward's off the base and the first NPC
that you can recruit is the old woman
from central yharnam who is just before
the rafters above the sewers she's
useless in the chapel right now but
after killing seven bosses she starts
giving you sedatives and starts treating
you like you're her child forget your
troubles forget your cares and after
you've killed three bosses Ariana and
the skeptical man can be sent to the
chapel as well you find them off to the
left immediately after you've unlocked
the main gate with the chief hunters
emblem and during this long misty Street
send Ariana to the chapel to continue
her quest line and then go to the
opposite house and talk to the skeptical
man if you've talked to your CEFCU in
her clinic you'll have two options here
the man will go to the opposite of
whatever you tell him to do so tell him
to go to yourself cos clinic and he'll
go to the chapel I'm not going to tell
you why right now but you do want him in
the chapel not yosef cos clinic we'll
get to that later
sorry even their lively predicable for
now though go down this alleyway and
make sure you pick up the black church
hunters set while you're here because we
need it to recruit one more NPC a little
bit later after you've killed the blood
staffed beast in all the Arnim Snatchers
will appear in your world the easiest
one to get to is right outside the front
entrance of Odin chap
off to the right and around the corner
dyed wood on purpose and then you'll
awaken in the hyper Djinn Jail then
travel down the stairs to your right and
you'll come across Adela put on that
black church hunter garb we picked up
earlier in the alleyway and she'll come
down to the point where you can send her
over to oedon chapel if you decide to
withhold information she'll be found
dead later in the streets near a pack of
dogs so now we have five NPCs in our
chapel and all of them have very
interesting interactions with each other
first off the skeptical man will give
you information on every character in
the chapel as you play through the game
an interesting thing about this is as
with everything he says the exact
opposite is true
weasal as emergent part on telling young
when you talk to Ariana she'll give you
a vial of her special blood which will
heal you instantly as well as give you
extra stamina regeneration for a short
time afterwards it states that a member
of the old healing church would know
that her blood is similar to what was
once forbidden Adela from the healing
Church does actually notice this and
clearly hates Ariana one of the
freakiest things I discovered was that
when you talk to Ariana Adela will
actually turn her head from where she's
sitting and watch you two talking like
she's jealous of you that's really weird
when you go and talk to Adela she won't
give you her blood if you're carrying
Ariana's blood she's that jealous in
fact if you consume Ariana's blood more
than three times after killing vicar
Amelia Adela will murder
Ariana out of jealousy Adela's blood
gives a health boost and then continues
to regenerate your health twenty seconds
afterwards you need to be careful of
consuming more than three sedatives from
the old woman as well because once she
gives them to you she will leave the
chapel to go outside to look for more
and that doesn't end well he find her
corpse near some graves later on and we
haven't mentioned this door yet I don't
think the one on the right side of the
chapel after the blood starved beast is
dead
it will open allowing you to continue
into the church workshop and pick up
Ludwig's holy blade however if you run
around to the left or right of the
ground level you can actually drop down
to two secret areas the first secret
area is the abandoned
workshop which you can access by going
forward here then turning left and
walking slowly off this platform and
then you'll land perfectly near the door
the second area is at the bottom and
it's a secret little village that loops
back into Cathedral Ward and also allows
you to bypass the door that requires the
chief hunter emblem to open you end up
here near the wooden plank shield gate
and if you go over the ladder you'll
find the numbing mist which is an item
we're going to need for the next boss
Emilia is very difficult and probably
not someone you should tackle as soon as
you arrive she has this huge variety of
tax a gigantic health pool and the
ability to heal and if I had to give
quick tips for her I'd say that you
should spend a few fights learning her
moveset and then when you're ready you
bring 20 blood vials you bring weapon
buffs and most importantly numbing mist
when she's at about 30% health this
numbing mist will stop her from healing
you have six of these at this point in
the game and you need to use them wisely
if you intend on killing her with a very
unopp raised soon as you touch the skull
the night actually progresses and it
becomes darker and a few elements in
this area have changed most importantly
in my opinion you can get need ligarius
wheel now it's one of my favourite
weapons Alfred has moved to his second
location and now that he's in his second
location he has an extra dialogue option
and he drops the wheel hunter badge if
you kill him here if you want to try and
kill him and get the wheel this early in
the game you I reckon you should watch
this video I made on how to get every
weapon as quickly as possible you can
check that out here but that's pretty
much it guys we've got two more videos
coming up this week one is things you
missed in the hunters dream another is
things you missed in all the arnhem and
these are both too like really easy to
make videos for me so I'm going to get
those out as soon as possible because I
want there to be content that's out
there and being released while I work on
some lore videos and the lore videos are
going to be great for this game we've
got three lore explained videos coming
up we've got prepared to cry coming up
and I want to spend a long time working
on these so I hope you look forward to
it and enjoy the other content that's
going to be going on in the meantime
but thanks for watching and I'll see you
next time